my name is Amy caption ski I'm a
professor of law here at Yale as well as
the co-director of the global health
justice partnership and the co-chair of
the Global Health Studies Program so
before I introduce professors reveal I
wanted to extend thanks to the event
organizers particularly Poonam and Jamie
who've done enormous amounts to make
this happen as well as the sponsors so
they yell global studies program the
global health justice partnership also
our many co-sponsors including the Yale
Council on Latin American and Iberian
studies Yale anthropology department the
shell Center for International Human
Rights the Yale School of Public Health
Department of Social and Behavioral
Sciences the sociology department and
the Solomon Center for the health
foreign policy as well as the osram rib
housing fund at the Yale Law School
all of them helped support this event
the structure is that will have a top as
well then Q&A with the audience and then
a reception from 6:00 to 7:00 where
we'll have the chance to talk a bit more
informally so we're just thrilled to
have a child here tonight with us as
part of the Global Health Studies
Program inaugural health justice speaker
series our series aims to bring to
campus scholars who expand and deepen
our conceptions of global health and
particularly in interdisciplinary
fashion and that's precisely what Jeff
which was illuminating in bold body of
work does spanning disciplines
geographies issues methods and
approaches so he is the Susan Dodd Brown
professor of anthropology and faculty
associate of the Woodrow Wilson School
of Public and International Affairs at
Princeton University as well as the
co-director of the Global Health Program
notice another undergraduate global
health program and of the Brasil lab at
Princeton yields a doctorate in
anthropology from Berkeley and a
doctorate in religion from the Graduate
theological Union as you can tell from
the diverse set of groups who
co-sponsored this event his work is
influenced multiple discipline
and ideas because it is in deep ways
cross-cutting and innovative his
research and teaching centers on medical
anthropology the social studies of
science and technology Global Health
pharmaceuticals religion and society and
broadly ethnography critical theory and
they may be contemporary subjectivity in
recent years he has authored Vita a life
in his own of social abandonment and
will to live aids therapies in the
politics of survival
both are award-winning books and
excellent ethnographic studies that
explore the new geographies of access
and marginalization that have emerged
alongside pharmaceutical globalization
he's also co-authored when people come
first critical studies in global health
and subjectivity ethnographic
investigations as well as the book
series critical global health Duke
University Press
one of the things that I find so
impressive about his work is in fact its
ability to move across disciplines in a
way that allows him both to do work
that's thought of I think by the people
inside of his discipline and who are not
as cross-disciplinary as he is the best
version of that discipline and who also
writes papers of the sort that somebody
who's a law professor reads with the
same amount of enthusiasm and
appreciation so that's that kind of
interest parent work is extraordinarily
rare I've just had the sense from our
conversations that part of what is so so
enables that kind of interdisciplinary
work is an incredible generosity of
spirit that you have towards other
disciplines just this afternoon he
talked with admiration about engineers
and economists and social scientists and
even maybe lawyers so I think that is
part of what what makes the work so
lively and so important across so many
disciplines is its depth of engagement
and its generosity in fact as well as
its intellectual seriousness I would say
you know this is work that brings also a
character
both critical and holistic and
people-centered approach to global
health a field that is not for all it's
sort of attempt at protecting humans
always very people centered he cares
deeply about the real persons and places
in which he works and for those of us
who are invested in global health I
think there's an enormous amount to be
learned from his approach as well as the
great body of work that he's built as
you know tonight he'll be speaking with
us about the judicialization of the
right to health in Brazil enacting
magical legalism and prospecting
biopolitical Futurity so it is an honor
and a pleasure to have you here please
join me in welcoming our speaker hello
everyone thank you Amy for the kind
introduction and warm welcome it's a
great pleasure to be here I want to
thank Amy Bragg Ali and Jaime for the
invitation and the staff of the Google
Health Studies program and the Jackson
Institute for their incredible help as
well as the Department of Anthropology
and the other co-sponsors of this event
I like to think of the social sciences
as always beginning in the middle way
and that each one of our ventures is a
new beginning as TS Eliot would put it a
raid on the in articulate for us there's
only the trying this trying is for sure
a plural undertaking the work I'm going
to share with you Springs from pressing
complex socio miracle legal realities
and it only took some scholarly form
with the aid of multiple local
stakeholders in Brazil and a most
wonderful and truly interdisciplinary
and move a method research team
particularly the epidemiologist Joe Amon
who has worked for Human Rights Watch
and is now a professor in the School of
Public Health at Drexel University the
physician and health policy scholar
mariana Sekou assistant scientist johns
hopkins university the anthropologist
and science studies scholar Adrina
patrina a professor at University of
Pennsylvania and the wonderful
photographer
Turban s corrode and
activist and scholar Deborah genies and
I will be showing some images by both
Torben and Deborah throughout my
presentation this is very much work in
progress I look forward to your comments
and questions so let me begin across the
Americas we leave in exhausted worlds
worlds on the edge of autocracy of
financial collapse of infrastructure
breakdown and environmental tipping
points mediated by extreme populism and
efforts to dismantle piecemeal though
meaningful agendas or socio-economic
rights along the enduring violence and
deadly health disparities realities that
are time and again couched in a wrath
reek of recovery even as conditions
stagnate or worsen meanwhile experts
claim to represent reality with more and
more modelling opaque measurements and
faulty predictions which are all too
often over simplifying and
depoliticizing where in these polls
models trials and projections is there
room for the plasticity of social worlds
for the contingent political decision or
legal swerve the unexpected mobilization
of flight that sets history and people
on an unforeseen course and how I meet
today's alarming global political shifts
can we account for the destructive and
violent potentials of people's plastic
power shaped as much by fear and
resentment as by need and desire what
kinds of social science
what sort of theory what kinds of
ethical political and affective
commitments can prefer a plumb line of
sorts when the anchors of truth seem
seriously adrift scholarly diagnosis of
the present moment can convey a sense of
dwindling possibilities in undoing the
demos political theories Wendy brown
argues that the encroachment of
neoliberalism into all his fears of life
is destroying democracy and the broader
political realm her assessment is bleak
quote neoliberalism is the rationality
which capitalism finally swallows
humanity in cruel optimism critical
theorist Lauren Breeland highlights the
frame of the so called normative good
life of American late liberal capitalism
that promised the permeability stability
intimacy and equality for all for
Berland desire and the possibility of
imagining alternative futures and are
somehow already in the service of or
only thinkable within the logics of
failed social systems yet might even the
cruelest of optimism's open unto
something else in the past two decades
my major at no graphic projects as any
man should have explored the new
geographies of rights and abandonment
that have emerged alongside
pharmaceutical globalization in a
restructuring Brazil particular around
hiv/aids and mental illness a major
player in the political economy of
pharmaceuticals in the global south and
boasting a universal healthcare system
Brazil offered fertile ground for
thinking through the unanticipated ways
people mobilized for treatment from the
government and the market in context of
stark inequality as afflicted
individuals and makeshift communities
scavenge for resources in care they find
themselves entangled in novel bio
medical and pharmaceutical rationalities
and in altered forms of common sense
amid the growing tension between health
as a public or private good and the
reconceptualization of care as a
technological intervention rather than a
relational practice from this
ethnographic sensorium one comes to
understand economic globalization state
and medical reforms and the acceleration
of claims to human rights how they
coincide with and impinge on a local
production of social death one also
comes to discern a distinct sense of
grassroots politics in which people's
let's keep them plural devise social
relations mobilize their wants and find
legal means of holding states locally
accountable thus creating alternative
capacities in the meantime of his
struggle as I like to call it amid dire
infrastructural conditions meanwhile
Brazil has experienced at the alignment
between its major political parties and
society exacerbated by social media
this process has enhanced the power of
populist rhetoric and authoritarian
drives to hijack electoral politics as
we saw in the recent presidential
election of the former Army captain
chair bosun re while people powered
action might not produce a grand new
utopia or the direct means for a
systemic alternative local mobilizations
for progressive policies and the
capitalization of opportunities even in
conservative and polarizing scenarios
none of the layers speaks the distinct
sense of politics in the making and of
an ongoing democratization of society
even alongside a resurgent
authoritarianism we know that we will
lose but we will keep trying Paula Bird
Oulu a professor of law and an attorney
with the center for law and social
transformation in Buenos Aires
he stated at a conference in Princeton a
reproductive health politics last spring
Bergamo who is currently a visiting
fellow at Yale was speaking of her
team's efforts along with the hundreds
of thousands of Argentinian woman who
have taken to the streets and the courts
in recent years to raise awareness about
domestic violence and to press for a
stronger laws to protect women as well
as for the legalization of abortion
while the juice accessibility of
socio-economic rights is of increasing
interest internationally know where it
is more pronounced than around health in
Latin America a region marked or
pervasive and rule of law and then in
the past three decades witnessed the
ratification of democratic constitutions
with a whole range of human rights
commitments my current research
addresses the meeting points of Medicine
and law in Brazil in 1988 people's the
people's constitution of 1988
it was called declared health as the
right of our persons and the duty of the
state and the creation of the country's
universal health care system called
Sue's extended free health coverage to
all citizens since the early 2000s in
the wake of a successful universal age
treatment policy that put Brazil in the
international spotlight a growing number
of citizens have been seeking and
sometimes realizing access to treatment
through the courts a phenomenon that has
been termed the judicialization of the
right to health through though
individual patients and patient
associations are suing the government
for everything from baby formula to
complex surgeries a large portion of
lawsuits are for access to medicines
with increasing number of cases has come
controversy over the phenomenon and its
consequences contrary to claims by
public officials and the media the
judicialization is driven primarily by
urban elites and private interests in my
ethnographic study I found that right to
health litigation is in fact a
widespread practice accessible even to
the very poor this judicialization of
health and folds in a landscape of
widespread dissatisfaction with
overworked health care system as
Brazil's current meltdown shows state
resources are being used and depleted to
shore up particular political projects
and interests a national survey in 2014
at the peak of anti-corruption outprice
and anti Workers Party public
demonstrations showed that an
overwhelming 45% of brazilians listed
health as the country's principal
concern and this interest in how people
work through available legal mechanisms
and the judiciary to claim access to
medical technologies and care when it
states mechanisms fail them that zone
where medicine and law intersect in
unexpected and deeply personal ways and
where our notions of how medicalization
and biopolitics operate from the bottom
up
we thought Paulo Bergamo
and other Lu Duras generative
communities are seizing on the changing
role of legally the legality and
expanding political role of the
judiciary in the region to press for
systemic change in the advancement of
women's reproductive rights they stand
for a creative political shift in the
shift regalos words in how human rights
have entered constitution of
deliberation in democratizing Latin
America for Bergamo a homegrown and
gendered form of your rights
constitutionalism is now in order while
the immediate advocacy of these efforts
at feminist legal reconceptualization
and jurisprudence still awaits empirical
assessment the gallic counters
criticisms of fertility with a long
delay imaginative approach we are doing
magical legalism she says and when the
political opportunity arises and it can
even be in conservative times we will
have our weapons in place in rejecting a
sense of deadening bleakness where gallo
casts present-day feminist legal
activism as part and parcel of an
imperfect form of politics which his
theorizes as akin to magical realism to
chiefly Latin American narrative
strategy characterized by the
matter-of-fact
inclusion of fantastic elements into
seemingly realistic fiction and which
found its canonical incarnation in
Gabrielle Garcia Marquez's classic 100
Years of Solitude
where lived time is certainly not
reducible to clock time insisting upon
action even amid an incongruous
political present burglars magical
legalism holds open possibilities for a
future otherwise in the past few decades
the law has indeed been a favored mode
of action in countries transitioning
from military to democratic regimes with
an international human rights system
playing a key role in that liberalizing
and Rapala G's such as Sally
angle Mary have shown that quote the
existence of a transcendent system of
human rights even vaguely defined gave
strength to local demands for justice
mark geudael and nancy post aro have
argued that a judicial contestation of
governance that accompanied neoliberal
reforms in latin america
it speaks to quote new ideological
landscapes an alternative frameworks for
social change that is new horizons of
possibility Bergamo and cover 'it's do
not subscribe to the notion that we are
now facing the end of human rights given
the shift in the global balance of power
from governments committed to human
right norms and toward those indifferent
or actively hostile to them as David
Reath recently noted in foreign policy
it is in the creative tinkering with the
earlier constitutional incorporation of
universal human rights that this new
generation of legal activists is
crafting a magical legalism there are
firms and otherwise to the constraining
limits of their here and now in doing so
they create the conditions of political
security the current experience of
Venezuelan migrants in Brazil and
Colombia is a most telling example of
how vital the constitutional right to
health can be both countries have
recognized if imperfectly their
obligations to ensure access to care for
the tens of thousands of migrants
crossing their borders from Venezuela
daily facing malnutrition chronic
conditions and infectious diseases I
start contrast to the rhetoric and
reality in the United States what is
extraordinary in the jurisprudence to
regenerative work of Bergamo and
colleagues and in the widespread right
health litigation that I have been
chronicling is that these practices
allow for the entry of diverse voices in
public debates about the object and
scope of the right to health the nature
of care through and beyond technology
and the public-private interface in
contemporary government institutions the
digitalization of health and of order
socio-economic
is not seamless it is a thorough genius
phenomenon that compels vulnerable
people's laws expert officials and
medical technologists to shuttle between
home hospital public offices streets and
courtrooms remaking those spaces and
themselves this peopling of
technologists and related to do
plasticity is thus a key lens for us to
identify emergent forms of people
powered action within preposterous
social orders and lopsided politicking
let me place this quest questions if
only crews early in historical
perspective two concurrent and
paradoxical trends informed the
structure of brazil's universal health
care system on the one hand there was a
trend toward a greater recognition of
the role of government in the
fulfillment of social rights in
democratizing brazil on the other hand
an our liberal theory of government
emphasized decentralization and
outsourcing of estate functions to the
private sector while the federal
government assumed the central role in
public health care funding regional and
municipal health departments had to
develop new structures to assess health
needs and to manage funds for the
delivery of care his arrangement
produced a delegation of responsibility
without ensuring funding compliance or
technical capacity for implementation
thus although brazil today has highly
progressive health policy many people go
to public pharmacies only to find that
essential medicines are out of stock and
that newer medicines that they seek are
not included in outdated drug
formularies in practice governments at
all levels have not been able to
effectively manage a complex healthcare
system under increasing technological
infrastructure and economic demands from
the public and private sectors which
themselves are becoming increasingly
indistinguishable as I documented in the
book will to live its therapies and the
politics of survival in the mid-1990s
Brazil became the first developing
country
to universalize access to antiretroviral
therapies about five years before global
policy discussions moved from a
framework that focused solely on
prevention to one that incorporated
universal treatment a breakthrough made
possible by an unexpected alliance of
activists government reformers public
science development agents agencies and
the pharmaceutical industry if brazil
aids policy was at once a significant
accomplishment and an evenly successful
the politics of its development and
consequences continue to play out in the
country today AIDS activists were among
the first to successfully equate
Brazil's constitutional right to health
with access to pharmaceuticals and in
the following years
this rights-based demand for treatment
access migrated to other diseases people
of all social backgrounds started to
file lawsuits to access medicines our
ruling by the Supreme Court in 2000
concerning a patient's access for a new
to a newer antiretroviral drug described
the aids from a suitable assistance
program as the actualization of the
government's duty to implement
programmatic norms that secure the
health of the population with such
programs as justice self Jamel argued
the right to health ceases to be quote
an inconsequential constitutional
promise what we are now seeing in Brazil
is a bio medical and legal shift in the
ways health issues are conceptualized
and addressed in terms of both delivery
and demand public health is now
understood less as prevention and
primary care and more as individual
access to medicines and community
outsourced care that is public health
has become increasingly pharmaceutical
iced and privatized
in the process the country is becoming a
profitable platform of global medicine
with one of the fastest growing from
Masuda coal markets in the world it is
estimated that about 50 percent of the
adult population uses from Masuda coals
on a continuous basis the idea of
pharmaceutical ization
builds on and revises the related notion
of medicalization understood as a form
of control that obscures the social
determinants of health by approaching
disease and treatment in exclusively
biomedical terms medical anthropologists
have rightly critiqued the
medicalization paradigm for being overly
deterministic while the culture of
biomedicine is undeniably powerful
people do not simply become the
diagnostic categories applied to them
they inhabit them to greater or lesser
degrees understanding our present-day
from acid equalization of health does
require moving beyond the only direction
of construction of patient subjectivity
by medical diagnostics and treatments to
account for the entanglement of multiple
social forms and markets the chemical
concreteness
and circulation of pharmaceuticals and
the role of patients agencies and
desires in the process the question of
what is frugal and essential to health
and well-being what one can do without
and what one has to have to survive is
evermore tangled and contested over the
last few years I have been collaborated
as I mentioned with various researchers
in the US and Brazil developing an
ethnographic and a statistical portrait
of the people who are turning to right
to health litigation particularly in the
southern state of rio grande de su with
a population of 11 million people the
state has seen a sharp increase in
health related lawsuits as you can see
in this in this image rising from over
1,000 new cases in 2002 to over 17,000
cases in 2009 the period when we started
to do this collaborative research
roughly said that 70 percent of this
lawsuits were for access to medicines by
2011 through Canada Sula the highest
number of health-related lawsuits in the
country with more than 100,000 pending
cases consider rinaldin who sued the
state for medication to treat her
pulmonary hypertension
the 50 year old woman lives with a
husband a taxi driver in a shantytown in
the capital porto alegre where the
couple runs an informal bar in the front
portion of their brick Shack Brunhilde
found out she was hiv-positive in 2002
she did not have trouble accessing a
high-cost antiretroviral therapies which
she received for free in the local
health post in early 2009 however
Pernilla began feeling out of breath and
be able to perform her duties as a
custodian she lost her job a doctor at
the local health was prescribed her
medication for pulmonary hypertension
unlike her hiv/aids treatment the
medicine was not offered to the public
healthcare system and at the time cost
about $1,000 a month the treatment
following her doctor's advice
Pernilla went to the public defender's
office and filed a lawsuit
welcome to the juridical hospital said
Paola in to the soldier the attorney in
charge of right to health litigation in
the public defender's office a portal
aggie her office is where the poor lycra
Nilda gets free legal assistance and
where the majority of the lawsuits
requesting medicines from the state
originate Sosa did not mince words in
describing what she thought the state's
biopolitics
had become when there are no defined
public policies or when they exist but
are not executed or when policies are
not in touch with no maladies and
medical advancements what do we have we
have a disease citizen we are beyond
preventative medicine here and the
concept of health as physical mental and
social well-being is no more
she continued when this sick person
comes to me the cure is most likely no
longer possible her right to health has
been profoundly injured by public power
a retired bus driver it gar was dealing
with significant motor difficulties he
had to wait for more than a year for an
appointment with an ER
at a portal a glee public hospital and
he was when he was finally diagnosed
with hereditary cerebral ataxia in 2008
gar was prescribed the drug soma xena
which is not included in any
governmental drug formulary raised in a
destitute family Edgar had been working
since the age of 8 and he proudly showed
me his workers ID card as a child he was
proud of the gated brick-and-mortar
house he had built himself well it gnar
felt that so Medina was helping to how
to generate the dinner direct
degeneration of his motor abilities he
was also taking other drugs from his
students to antihypertensives
to antidepressants to soothe additional
symptoms at his dining room table
edgar opened a box containing the five
medicines that make up his regimen as he
held each one in turn he said this one I
done judicial ice this one I done two
dish a lies this one I'd gone to dish
Allies I only judicial eyes this one
because I got in that paying for it a
monthly supply of soma xena costs about
$200 after paying for the drug
out-of-pocket for several months
Edgard had to take out a bank loan
unable to keep up with household
expenses and the interest on his lawn he
said that he had quote no alternative
but to judicial ice and filed a lawsuit
with the help of Sousa at the public
defender's office a district judge
issued a court injunction on a guards
behalf and he received the medicine for
several months until the delivery
stopped he then filed a new claim
winning another injunction for three
additional months of treatment as for
why he was not judicial izing the other
drugs he was taking edgar reasoned i
know that the state cannot give
everything to everyone i have to do my
part and pay for whatever I can
the lawsuit is only one part of Edgar's
treatment complex and even the efficacy
of his own
education was uncertain judicialization
is not an attractive option to begin
with although it saves him money it gar
must periodically renewed a lawsuit with
no guarantee that drug delivery will
continue in some sense Adar prefers the
position of consumer to that of citizen
as it gives him more control and
confidence the market in the sense is
more reliable than the welfare state the
medicine box is a Guard survival kit yet
what does not fit in this box is the
psychosocial care for example that could
help a guy improve his quality of life
as the disease progresses a lawsuit
would not help him gain access to such
services the stories of patient
litigants like Ranil de and agar
illuminate the overlapping subject
positions that individuals occupy as
they procure precarious access to
treatment through the market and the
courtroom balancing clinical needs with
shifting boundaries of personal and
public responsibility while examining
distance negotiations of the
constitutional right to health in daily
life I often also had a sense that
social roles and institutional positions
were out of place the judiciary was
acting as a sort of a pharmacy the
public defender as a physician the
physician as an activist the patient
Association as legal counsel the patient
citizen was becoming a consumer and
cost-cutting public of officers had
kidnapped the discourse on equity in
their anti judicialization campaigns
debates over the wise house and effects
of the ever-expanding judicialization of
the right to health in Brazil and across
Latin America have been marked by
polarized arguments and limited
information
a majority of judicialization studies
have used imperfect data focused on
short-term outcomes and implicitly or
explicitly advocated for its containment
and management arguing that right when a
litigation is
people public-health of policies and
budgets and that by overruling the
autonomy of the bureaucracy it also
reduces efficiency and increases
inequality individual plaintiffs demands
are presented as the antithesis of a
supposed collective need and actual
people their health seeking struggles
and hopes are nowhere to be found
whether to evidence-based Public Health
at all costs
many of these critics also fail to
recognize that right to health
litigation can be an urgently needed
corrective when administrative channels
fail people in dire circumstances and
that judicialization can itself be a
source of practice-based evidence to
respond to the need for more
comprehensive knowledge of the struggle
to realize the right to health our team
collected data on lawsuits requesting
medicines from the state of Uganda to
sue we accessed the health department's
electronic registry and after selecting
a random starting point we
systematically collected every sixth
case opened during 2008 the first year
this data was available totalizing a
thousand two hundred and sixty two cases
in the sample right now the largest
sample in studies of digitalization in
brazil the result of our the results of
our research challenge many common
assumptions about Briarcliff litigation
offering an empirical counter two widely
circulated views from this localised
people-centered perspective
digitalization emerges as a complex and
dynamic element of a faltering health
system and as a critical dimension of
democratic life let me show you some of
our results of the litigant population
we sampled a little over over half were
female and the vast majority 92% lived
outside the state capitol showing how
geographically widespread this
phenomenon is individuals who
digitalized were also predominantly
older while past research has suggested
that right-half litigation is for the
most part a practice of
financially better off our findings
showed this to be false at least in
southern Brazil among the plaintiffs who
reported their employment status more
than half were either retired or
unemployed although we do not have
direct data on income about close to 60
percent of plaintiffs were represented
by the public defender's office which
provides free legal assistance only to
poor and low-income individuals about a
third of Rio Grande de Sol's 496
municipalities have a public defender's
office and it is likely that his
presence increases individuals access to
justice as well as understandings and
expectations of Rights at the community
level our data also found misconceptions
also corrected misconceptions about the
character and cost of medications sought
overall
seventy-three percent of plaintiffs
requested at least one medicine that was
already part of governmental drug
formularies that is they should have
been available in the public health care
system forty-one percent of the
plaintiffs requested on formulary
medicines exclusively while twenty seven
percent like Ronald and God requested
off formulary medicines exclusively the
vast majority of cases eighty percent
indicated treatment was requested for
continuous duration reflecting the
chronic character of the diseases that
afflict is older by and large older
patient citizens the most frequently
requested medicines were for common
problems such as asthma hypertension
cholesterol and mental illness they were
part by a large of official drug
formularies and had therapeutic
protocols defined by the Ministry of
Health
most patients had comorbidities and
required multiple medicines you know
close to three medicines per lawsuit
these results suggest that government
pharmaceutical programs are failing to
fulfill their role of expanding access
and rationalizing use and that a poor
legally empowered are trying to make
this
system redress this failure contrary to
common assumptions litigants mostly
sought low-cost
drugs like a guard the vast majority 75%
requested medicines with a monthly cost
below $250 treatments right but the vast
majority of patients and you can see in
this in this image that that there was
no significant that high cost lawsuits
composed the minority of the sample and
that overall on and our formulary
medicines is not diverse significantly
in terms of cost just as a majority of
plaintiff requested medicines that were
part of governmental drug formularies a
large number of plaintiffs initially
tried to secure treatment through local
administrative channels turning to
digitalization only when this channel
failed an eighty five percent as you see
in this figure of losses including a
physician issued prescription or a
report confirming the need of treatment
and the great majority were written by
doctors from the public health care
system this was the case of 16 year old
Leticia and nine year old T'Challa who
live on the outskirts of Port Alegre
both sisters suffer from phenacetin
Oriya or PKU a metabolic genetic
disorder the difference that the younger
sister CACI Ali was immediately
diagnosed and treated with a combination
of diet and medication latisha the elder
was not enough suffers from severe
intellectual disability Leticia was only
diagnosed because her sister was born
after screening had become mandatory and
the special baby formula needed to
prevent the development of the disease
had become universally available via the
public healthcare system about a hundred
and twenty patients in the state need
this special milk formula but given
distribution problems 25 families had to
file lawsuits
to ensure access we interviewed all
litigant families who for the most part
live in the interior and are very poor
once when the government failed to make
the formula available Navy and mariachi
the girls daughters told us we also
filed a lhasa they did so with support
of dr. paula vargas the girls beloved
physician as dr. Vargas said this
patient simply cannot go without
treatment it would be a crime while
waiting for distribution to resume the
caring doctor helped the family to get
in touch with other PKU families who in
solidarity lent them their own formula
other families went to local newspapers
and radio stations to decry their plight
as one mother told us NOS pusimos entrar
nauseous chisa EDI nang crane sir we
have to first enter justice or the
judiciary and then the medium strikingly
in almost all of the lawsuits we studied
the judges granted the plaintiffs an
immediate injunction demanding the state
to provide the requested drugs
explaining this was consistent with
Brazil's constitutional obligations to
fulfill the right to help to investigate
whether judges took governmental norms
for drug provision into consideration we
also analyzed the frequency with which
judges ruled on the provision of
generics and here you can see in 76
percent of the cases they prescribe
generics and from the sample of lawsuits
where there was explicit reference to
the drug form in some counter to
prevailing anti digitalization
narratives our results reveal a process
of judicialization from below stemming
from low-income and older individuals
who do not live in a metropolitan in the
major metropolitan areas the local
presence of a public defender's office
is a key institution or factor driving
this grassroots mobilization as is a
responsive judiciary in a new geospatial
analysis that we are now doing we are
finding that municipalities with a
public defender's office had seventh
verse
times more likely to have a right to
health lawsuit then municipalities
without a public defender's office and
that municipalities with greater
availability of health services had
overall a slightly lower number of
lawsuits in addressing a dysfunctional
health system that fail to provide for
their needs poor patients face the
option of either seeking costly
private-sector alternatives or voicing
concerns through cumbersome
participatory mechanisms like community
health wards our study shows though that
through right to health education some
Brazilian cities are finding new ways of
concretizing voice as Albert Hirschman
would have it through a process of
introduced chicer entering justice
acting as political subjects to hold the
state accountable and exposing the
disastrous realpolitik of executive and
legislative bodies like attorney Paulo
into the saucer judge of jannat era who
oversees all health-related losses in
Porto Alegre finds that lawsuits are
largely filed by poor and desperate
patients seeking treatment that should
be available in the public system I'm
doing social justice
one by one he told me when I'm issuing
an injunction for cancer treatment
provision I'm also in dining services
that have not kept up with people's
needs our analysis of losses also showed
that when patients sought new
technologies not yet included in
obsolete benefits packages the federal
government tended to incorporate it they
requested technologies into official
policies later among the twenty most
frequently requested of formulary
medicines in our sample seven have been
incorporated in the governmental
formulary since 2008 including the most
expensive one while in no way a magic
bullet for broader structural political
problems judicialization canonical SB
understood as a significant mechanism of
both accountability and responsiveness
highlighting gaps in the health system
and sometimes however modestly
dressing them the state has evolved in
his response to digitalization
throughout the country health
administrators have started to designate
staff and implement software systems to
manage court obtain treatments new
public pharmacists were established to
exclusively store and provide judiciary
of ten treatments effectively creating
parallel delivery systems of judicial
and non-judicial drugs within the public
health system general attorney offices
have organized Task Force focus on
health litigation designating teams to
work exclusively on health related
lawsuits medical consultants have been
brought in to help prepare evidence base
defenses and because health related
lawsuits inundated courts specific
jurisdictions have been appointed to
concentrate these cases in some cities
mediation courts have been created to
resolve claims to medicines before
lawsuits even started despite these
steps information on judicialization
remains restricted while government
officials blame judicialization for
disrupting health policies public
administrators often do not release data
that would allow an open examination of
right health litigation if it's being
conducted by whom and who benefits from
it in some cases agencies are creating
barriers to data access instead of
reducing them his affiliation matters
claims about the costs and benefits of
digitalization
and its relationship to equity in health
require analysis of procedural justice
as well as human capabilities and such
analysis requires detailed data in a
recent article my colleagues and I
argued for greater data availability and
open access and for extending the focus
of digitalization study beyond the
claims formation and adjudication stages
to its implementation stage and social
outcomes multi source of the stakeholder
mixed-method approaches can help us
capture the Eternity and dynamism of
judicialization and to both understand
its extra aim
and identify factors that can provide
actionable targets to improve policies
ultimately we should seek to produce
real-time data that can help drive
advancement towards transparent and
participatory priority setting as well
as accountability mechanisms that
promote quality universal health care
coverage I want to conclude with a few
comments on the aftermath of the recent
Zika epidemic which speaks to the
dynamic evolution of right to health
litigation in Brazil the Zika virus
arrived in the country in 2015 and as of
now an estimated 4,000 children have
been affected by the congenital syndrome
even though Zika has been present in the
biomedical literature since the 1950s it
was only with the Brazilian outbreak
that effects of the virus on fetal
development were identified as the
anthropologist the aborigines puts it in
this story where a mundane disease of
the tropics proved to be a source of
tremendous distress for a woman the key
protagonists were not physicians and
scientists but mothers to be indeed the
woman whose pregnancies were affected by
Zika embodied multiple markers of
difference they lived in historically
dispossessed and precarious
infrastructure areas in the country's
poorest northeastern region they were
mostly black brown and indigenous woman
who lacked regular access to health care
and information on contraception and
family planning the impact of Zika on
this woman and their families shows that
the right to health is not only
individual but also collective thus
requiring a focus on population health
and community interventions it also
reminds us that right to health is not
only the right to treatment but also the
right to prevention supported by a broad
range of social policies Brazil once
effectively controlled the EDA's
mosquitoes that carry Zika as well as
dengue and chikungunya virus but years
of neglect allowed their resurgence lack
of distribution of basic prevention
resources and well water collection and
sanity
systems allowed the mosquitoes to spread
the failure to fulfill the right to
health in the case of Zika continues
even after transmission has declined as
the health system is unable to provide
appropriate and adequate care to babies
affected by the Zika syndrome meanwhile
widespread outrage over the multiple
social and political determinants that
shield epidemic has created a propitious
environment for a renewed debate of a
reproductive rights and the
decriminalization of abortion in Brazil
in line with efforts in neighboring
Argentina activist groups seized the
occasion to decry the fact that highly
vulnerable woman had to submit to
compulsory pregnancy in the face of
severe public health emergency abortion
is basically a riot in Brazil is
basically I'm in Brazil it is only legal
in cases of rape when necessary to save
a woman's life or when the fetus suffers
and it's awfully studies estimated one
in five brazilian woman has had an
illegal abortion by the age of 40 given
Brazil's current conservative political
scenario it was not feasible to
challenge the crib the the
criminalization of abortion via Congress
attorney Gabriela rendang told me so in
August 2016 2016 feminist activists in
alliance with the National Association
of public defenders petition the
Brazilian Supreme Court using a
comprehensive social rights framework
they requested both individual and
collective remedies for those affected
by Zika the demands were simple access
to information and prevention tools
timely attention to health facilities
and specialized care transportation to
care centers for babies living in remote
areas and access to family planning
among others the law should also
challenge the criminalization of
abortion on the grounds that pregnant
women experiencing mental health impacts
from contract from the Zika virus during
pregnancy should have the option to
interrupt the pregnancy the case has
helped has read has helped reignite a
vigorous national debate with thousands
of reports in the media
and the peso political party filing a
separate case challenging the
criminalization of abortion in the first
twelve weeks of pregnancy rather than
resorting to the ideas of autonomy or
privacy the team of young feminist
attorneys Gabriela rendang and sonarak
Umi arey to my right they use the
constitutional principles of human
dignity and of citizenship in their
arguments to a given socio-economic
inequalities white women with higher
incomes are able to exercise their
self-determination regarding abortion
even in the context of illegality while
poor women are left constrained between
extremely unsafe abortion or compulsory
maternity the criminalization of
abortion does it 10 suffice what they
call their second-class citizenship
hezron don't recently told me a Queen
Paola Burgos remark about magical
legalism we believe that there is no
preset architecture or roadmap for
litigating for reproductive justice and
every new case has represented both
continuity and rupture with previous
debates and efforts we need to be ready
to be both creative and sensitive to
historical and political moment so that
when there is a chance we can make a
social difference the Supreme Court
which has been consumed by a series of
cases on corruption not to mention the
impeachment of President Dilma Rousseff
and the arrest of former President Luiz
inácio Lula da Silva will issue its
ruling this coming May the story of Zika
and is activist aftermath raises
important questions about what drives
digitalization on the ground and the
impact of judicialization on a broader
understanding of the state's obligation
to fulfill the right to health both
individual and collective what appeals
superficially as individual
vulnerability and demands for care
ultimately reflects of collective
condition of underlying structural
precariousness
similarly what appears as an individual
response litigation can also be seen as
a collective movement to press for local
and systemic change seen from this
perspective judicialization is part of
democratic life something to be
understood in its complexity and
possibly tinkered with or reoriented so
to promote substantive human rights
people refuse to be stratified out of
existence using any means available to
poke holes in macro models and
population level calculations that could
hold their lives kept it or delimit
their life chances they're hard to pin
down
- aided subjects like patient citizens
consumers introduced throughout this
talk speak to novel forms of social
becoming at the interface of medicine
and law their medical legal trajectories
show that politics matters differently
the growing number of sick and
vulnerable low and middle-income
brazilians and their legal partners
engaged as they are in the plastic and
ever-evolving twin phenomena of the
pharmaceutical ization and
digitalization of health litigants may
not be establishing an imminent civil
society but they are establishing
themselves as people while navigating
the vagaries of market inclusion and
livability as part of our reticent and
contradictory out-there Commons they
demand workable infrastructures and
become the harbingers of a bio political
Futurity from below here the shape of
collectives and the right course of
action remain undetermined channeling is
unmoored social formation Lauda's
appears as the practical tool of an
otherwise the current moment after all
calls less for the all-knowing hubris of
totalizing analytical schemes than for
human science and politics of the
uncertain and they are known
[Applause]
started sort of as you sketched out for
us a lot of the debate around
judicialization has been through this
lens of equity right with the critic
saying individual cases of this sort the
very poorest can't bring them and
they're driving spending in ways that
are contrary to public health priorities
etc and and your work very powerfully
refutes some of those arguments I think
obviously you're only looking at at one
state and so forth but you have this
very powerful evidence as you walked us
through showing that in fact it's not
right to think that most of these
participants are middle class or
privileged in fact the majority seem to
not be both geographically and and
probably also sort of socioeconomic ly
and in fact most of the things they're
asking for are things that they're
entitled to under the existing programs
and so forth but you don't say you don't
say one more thing which I'm which which
might be the more decisive reputation of
this argument which is to say one of the
ways that these cases might be thought
to be driving priorities and ways that
are inequitable is that it's a very
small number of the drugs involved and
in fact probably a very small number of
the litigants to drive a huge amount of
the cost and so I think the last figure
that I saw came from around 2011 where
it was 80 percent of the cost come from
less than 1% of the litigants and just
20 drugs right and this is because of
what we know about pharmaceuticals which
is it's the really new expensive ones
that drive a huge amount of
pharmaceutical spending right and so you
don't really tight tackle that version
and and I wonder whether in some sense
that might suggest that there could be
both there could be two truths one that
in fact the majority of these cases just
are described by what you are
articulating as this kind of imminent
experience of citizenship that is in
fact forming new kinds of accountability
and that that in fact the overall
phenomenon has created dynamics that are
troubling from a kind of systemic
perspective if they're both true are
they both true if they're both true what
all we think about that is they're one
way that we are
what we ought to prioritize is the
imminent citizenship and with a Futurity
the the dynamic nature that this enables
what do you do with the public health
folks out there who might say no what we
ought to prioritize is sort of some more
solid heuristic or collective way of
setting priorities which would let us
let's say think about everybody and
contain costs in the way that we we
might without these that's my first
question maybe I maybe I'll just maybe
I'll maybe I'll see one more thing I'll
skip one of my other question I'll say
one more thing my other question is some
of the work that I've done and largely
driven by my simple tracking of what
activists in Brazil are doing is that
activists in Brazil some of the AIDS
activists that you mentioned who sort of
started this whole train going have also
brought to the courts cases where they
try to say let's take on the conditions
that make these very expensive drugs
expensive let's tackle the patent laws
and let's tackle the prices and they
bring arguments to these these courts
that in many ways are quite open to
claims about the right to health and
they say well the government should have
to lower the prices the government
should have to buy generic drugs the
government should have to take these
structural actions and the courts don't
do it which are quite resistant to the
sort of more structural kinds of claims
that might in fact address the if I'm
right about what one one critique of it
and so what which is why are the courts
resistant to that does that business
segment does that also tell us something
about what's going on in this moment of
of a kind of new form of citizenship
that is in fact maybe more deeply
neoliberal than the other phenomenon or
maybe they're both neoliberal I'm not
sure so it's just so so I offer those
both and then maybe if you wanted to
take a few questions from the audience
and articulation for the articulation of
a phenomenon and the key points that I
try to convey why the quartz resist oh
sorry
why the quartz resist you know the state
so there's really an empowerment of the
judiciary's we could see in Brazil for
good and for bad right there's a
political body really a strong one so
there is this phenomenon the
judicialization of politics a larger
phenomenon where the judiciary feels
that they they are one of the only sites
that can hold the legislative and
executive accountable to certain extent
so that's a larger phenomenon that has
been happening in Brazil over the past
two decades given the electoral forms of
politics right which basically have four
years in power and then you have the
resources you don't do nah you don't do
anything and then use the state
resources for reelection etc etc so that
so the courts do not buy the argument
that it's infringing on budgets because
the state has an obligation to to deploy
a certain percentage of tax collection
on the health system and it doesn't do
that so the argument that it produces
inequality for the courts does not hold
because the government is actually not
investing as much in health as it should
this is called the the reservoir of the
possible or is that with the receiver
that's a so courts are very reluctant
they tend to site at a lower level with
with the litigants because they know the
way local politics operates so the it's
very there's so many dimensions to
unpack I will try to say a few things
and then we collect more questions and
maybe the you know will craft the text
together here when we started this
project in delay mm you know 2009 in
2010 there was a dominant narrative
digitalization produces inequality and
that's that's a that's an essay that was
produced by Ekta both rise early
scholars and when we started to study
those studies they they have
very fragile evidence you know this is
an ideological argument that they're
making a point that they're making a
political statement but the data that
was used until then was Biscay based on
a studying some power based on zip codes
on a neighborhood in Sao Paulo and uh
and they assumed that this was like
middle-class neighborhood they never
thought it could be a maid so there was
not kind of an exploration was a very
circumscribed and limited but but so a
lot of the subsequent studies we're
really framed to make that point so we
said no we first need to understand but
the phenomenon is so that's what we
mapped got more people involved we tried
to get access to data but it's
interesting when we started to find
these results our partnership with the
state of Rio Grande ensued broke down
they didn't want us to publicize these
results
so the second database that I showed to
you today it took us two years and I
have to get access to we had done one
initial and we found the same results so
we almost have to judicial eyes just to
be able to get you know our database
because they were not happy with that
narrative so what's very interesting
that there was this alliance between by
a large public health research or some
ideological political argumentation by
legal scholars right and and that was
really at the serve what was taken up by
public officials who then said see
what's happening let's not even consider
this right so so in some ways so our job
was to try to create like an evidence as
robust as possible to try to deconstruct
their story and then when we presented
and produced this evidence then the
argument wait oh but this is an
exception this is the south of Brazil so
the discourse on exceptionalism starts
start to come in but it's the highest
number of cases in the country isn't the
state of ribbond so there's there's a
history of political activism or
judicial activism there as well that can
explain parts parts of that so the other
question that so there is something what
the scholars brought to the discussion
and the study of digitalization
not been problematized enough and I
think the the narrative of equity was so
interesting to me to have done this
legal scholars having the same discourse
as the very corrupt and conservative
officers so there was something was
puzzling to me and I and I so that's
that lack of reflexivity I think is
starting to break open now because there
are more and more studies taking place
it showed similar phenomenon as in the
south of Brazil with its own variation
throughout throughout the country the
question that you asked about the
expensive treatments we did a study part
of our study was also to working with a
team of geneticists in southern Brazil
certain relatives also a hub for genetic
for the clinical trials on genetic
therapies particularly NPS and we
followed you know both doctors who
recommend patients to the genetic trials
and then they take enzyme replacement
therapies which are the most expensive
in the market right those drugs just you
know that's the orphan drugs that if you
get you know like a drug for a treatment
up that cannot treat about two hundred
thousand people or something like that
you get a monopoly on the and the path
etc so it's a kill different model
different model than the blockbuster
model of drug development and so Brazil
became a hub for the testing of those
enzyme replacement therapy is genetic
therapies and those are treatments that
cost about two hundred thousand dollars
a year so that's and it's very
interesting that that at a look at a
regional level there were attempts to to
to make the from the the biotech company
of the pharmaceutical industry who was
carrying out the trials accountable to
cost of treatment after the trial was
over because what that was the
scandalous scenario the trial ended and
then the pharmaceutical industry helped
to create a patient association pay the
wire and then they went
to the courts and requested you know the
$200,000 treatments right so so that's
the extreme case and in Rubens oosoo
they created some kind of ruling that to
a certain extent binds the industry or
the biotech company to pay for the
treatment after the trial is over so
some of the companies left the state now
they went to other states
so it's a very migrant industry as well
and part of the clinical trials - we're
gonna Katrina that clinical trial
becomes a marketing tool to pay the
market in the country so you're
absolutely right that's part of the
story but but both officials and
scholars conflated that that was equal
to the phenomenon and as we showed here
you could see that's the outlier
it's a black box the relationship that
the Workers Party had with the
pharmaceutical industry so incredible
lobbying the question of why there was
no different kind of price negotiation
during the government it's hard to
understand but it seems that they try to
be a play on both fronts like the poor
get some kind of income get out of
terrible poverty but also let the rich
gets richer that's the contradiction I
think of the Workers Party rule in
Brazil
great so take a couple questions then
maybe if you just introduce yourselves
I'm Mindy Roseman I'm at Yale Law School
and I really thank you for your
provocative and counter a
counterintuitive arguments about use of
courts and realizing the right to health
and its distribution effect so I will
confess that I was part of the initial
wave in looking to see conceptually and
empirically about the effects of the
courts on health rights coming out in
the way of the wake of the Tak
litigation and then subsequent
litigation in South Africa which seemed
to at first acknowledge social rights
and rights to health and then took a
step back and looking much more
procedurally at as long as the
government was reasonable and so that
kind of circumscribed the entry point
and the work you cite of Octavia for us
actually published in a volume that I
helped produce which looked at sort of
taking the ideological I think
inspiration from maybe a Marxist
tradition that rates were bourgeois to
look at the ways in which the middle
class used the courts to consolidate
what they think are entitlements to
their citizenship and get right to
health so what I would say what you're
describing and I would love your
impressions and reflections on it are
both a certainly a response like a
systemic response you point to a factor
in our distinguishing factor which is a
public advocate or a public defender
accessibility in this jurisdiction and
maybe in all the jurisdictions where
people have access to courts that that's
a political commitment about
redistributing and having a kind of
social citizenship that can go into a
dysfunctional system that's not
delivering the social goods right and
they can make the claims on the state
that they're already entitled to it's
not terribly radical redistribution
but it is in countries and jurisdictions
where you don't have that have you
looked at the outcomes of similarly
situated litigation and and would you
say that that is in the legal
opportunity structure the distinguishing
factor we thought we might take a few
questions at once just the chance to
have more of you get a word in others
I'm Krystina talbert's like oh I know
you know me okay so I'm mindful that I'm
not versed in this literature and I
think this question might sound a little
bit naive but I'm so curious when you
quoted the public defender she said
something about the social mental
physical well-being that was a
definition of health and then and then I
found that you know as you were talking
and you've made the case extremely
compellingly that health and the
judicialization of health is really
about a biomechanical view of Health and
the pharmacal pharmacal ization of it
that's not a word that I often say and I
was curious about how the Constitution
defines health and how this definition I
know that's a naive question for the
lawyers in the room but the w-h-o
definition is social mental physical
well-being and I was curious about the
constitutional definition if there is
one and how this judicialization is
defining health and how the
pharmaceutical piece of it is defining
it in a biomedical way and how all those
things come together the Comoros would
say right from class struggle to class
action right in South Africa you know
but again that speaks to a certain way
of reading the phenomenon we know that
this was much more than that in South
Africa in South Africa the judiciary had
a different reading right of the of the
color of the collective you know there's
this the case right of 1996 right the
the patient who wants to have emoji
Alice's you know the court said no we
will not provide it to you but right you
you have to so the system has to change
just to make it available to everyone
locally right so it was a different kind
of ruling and it's very interesting that
question of the comparison right to see
the right health in Brazil South Africa
in India for example be interesting
India the high producer of generics but
availability universal access the
therapy is not necessarily but then the
right to food it's very interesting what
you know what's kind of mobilizes people
and how the judiciary navigates
you know the the state's view of of its
role to which kind of populations the
the public defenders are absolutely
right they are political actors and they
take their work as political actors
Brazil has a sort of a fourth power
which is the public ministry and this is
the ministry that people can actually
people can access the public ministry
and even file a lawsuit against the
president or hold the state accountable
and so the public ministry is supposed
to defend vulnerable peoples
particularly you know indigenous people
descendants of Ephraim afro-brazilians
descendants of slaves but also the
environment and the public ministry has
been a site where collective causes are
waged and they have a very conciliatory
role so that for example patient
associations of kids with genetic
disorders they go to the public ministry
and then public ministry accesses local
governments and mediates availability of
treatment etc etc it's very interesting
detrol but the public defenders they
have been a very highly politicized in
the state of rio grande do sul and it's
very interesting that in some Powell was
the last country they're the last state
in the country that had free legal
assistance so judicialization in my view
is intimately linked with access to
justice you know so the exception is not
really going to the zoo
the exception is some power right so
where people did not necessarily have
that possibility of litigating right so
the one thing that I you know I just
wrote my notes here and there I'm
rambling a little bit but hopefully
these things will be connected you know
together in our conversation AIDS
changed the rule of the game completely
and we cannot pretend that ideas we had
about policy and equality or even
economic ideas of the trickle-down
effect right oh we make the technology
in the north and then
fifteen 20 years it will find its way
into the South that that was changed
completely so why would we expect that
people knowing that there are
technologies available would not try to
access them and and that for me is an
absurdity that it's built in many
studies for example some Norwegian
scholars they go to believe you they are
filing a lawsuit for a drug that costs
$800 rather than investing on maternal
mortality but hey she is totally covered
in Norway and that treatment which she
needed would be available for free to
the healthcare system there so there is
a kind of like an you know there's
something assumed that the poor are so
sure that the the health care system as
it is it's enough for the poor you know
and AIDS change that through radically
and I and I'm not not making a judgement
you know there is a good or bad thing
but the fact is that public health has
been from a sudra class and the fact is
that people are not waiting for the
treatments to trickle down
they are mobilizing now it's a
complicated phenomenon because from a
civilization creates its own kind of
diseases conditions you're over
pharmaceutical eyes you know you're
treating one side effect with something
else maybe the the treatment should be
deep for masa legalization especially in
among the elderly right when
polypharmacy phenomenon but these are
like new medical social legal realities
that you know the subjects that we work
with and the political subjects are
wrestling with so a lot of the the first
wave of studies of judicialization they
had a certain idea of the people or of
society and for them the 90s you know
hiv/aids we had an imminent society so
activists were saying see those
activists they were fighting for the
collective it was not just for
individuals but that's it's kind of
myopic to imagine as dr. as Paola the
defender cells people come here they're
individuals but they are injured by
public power they are injured by
the way the sisters know prevention
place question of sanitation not to
mention not access to basic treatments
or coordinated you know therapeutics
with social services involved etc etc so
since some ways aids changed that game I
think and the public defenders and and
they are allied with this responsive
Judy shirt so the dick how could this be
politicized otherwise right it's obvious
like a key question it's a key question
how could be many times the patient
associations their dream is to become a
federal program so the patient
associations which are struggling with
genetic disorders among the kids they
want to become a federal program because
that's the program that worked that's
what made hiv/aids so successful because
of a central purchase you know the they
had public science involved that could
reverse engineering drugs initially you
know that was the model but then that
fell apart
then it became prey of the you know your
question of the pharmaceutical market
without clear mechanisms of bargaining
price and price reduction etcetera etc
but the idea a lot of it is to become
visible as a federal program in some
ways I think Brasilia presents this this
challenges that come with the
universalization of access to care in
the time where we have this expanding
field of technological innovation with
this overwhelming as you're working it
reveals so powerfully you know this is
political economy or pharmaceuticals
right that that is that is that has its
own kind of cartography of markets and
different regulatory price regimes
negotiations with countries diversity
and there is no there's no way to to
there's no mechanism in place that can
hold that accountable but federal
governments I would say and the federal
government's they are so invested with
finance be capital Big Pharma even
though if they are committed in
principle to equity so so it's a it's a
different kind of political legal
medical field on the grass
then my book tries to do to raise this
from the bottom up rather than from
assumptions that we already know what
the social is what the population is or
what the right course of action yes the
question that you asked about the
concept right the right to health the
scope not the object of the right to
health that's a crucial one but is the
object of right well I try to allude to
the ruling of salsiccia Melo who was the
supreme justice who ruled in favor of an
AIDS patient who wanted an
antiretroviral that was not part of the
of the of the formulary of the cluster
of drugs that were available and he'd
ruled in favor of that patient and I
think that's the crucial question right
because the judiciary is still saying
even though it's not approved by the
government or included officially in
governmental lists the state has the
obligation to provide so there's a
critical quick and that becomes an
opening of course for the market to come
in etc etc but that's still the ruling
of salsiccia Melo that's used in all
losses in all rulings by the judges
according Melo he said this that the
right to health is inconsequential if
there are no programmatic responses and
the AIDS policy becomes the embodiment
of what the state owes to the citizen I
think it's problematic I think some
groups you know are trying to break them
open ask questions what about sanitation
it's it's shameful the situation in
Brazil like some cities some mega cities
in the in the north and north east of
Brazil you know 95 percent without
sanitation so and then you have this
high-tech world right so it's it's a
complicated coexistence and I think Zika
you could see that happening in the
context of Zika as well but I think the
question of there is some coding of the
object
of the right to health in the way the
Supreme Court has ruled in favor of
patients demanding treatments that are
not part of protocols great yeah it's
fascinating as always and I actually
didn't know that you were really doing
this kind of research and so you know
thank you for sharing it with us first
of all I can't imagine at the part of
the world that I know best which is the
Middle East I can't imagine this kind of
scenario ever happening because you'd
have to have such a strong judiciary you
have to have lawyers who are activists
who are wanting to take on these kinds
of cases which i think is sort of
remarkable you know and and whether this
is not just in Brazil but other parts of
Latin America would be one question the
other thing is you know you talked about
patient groups and patients sort of
advocates see groups for example for
rare genetic diseases and that sort of
speaks to the issue of bio sociality
that groups are forming around
particular kinds of you know disease you
know groups but but are there many cases
where just individuals assume that this
is part of their right to go to court to
find a lawyer and do this are there many
cases that are sort of individually LED
and agentive I quite figured that out
from the presentation and that's
interesting if people are just saying
this is my right to do this and I'm
gonna go and you know try to get the
drug that I need and then finally beyond
that this was mostly about
pharmaceuticals but I could start to
think about things like you know that
aren't considered to be life-saving
kinds of interventions like your student
Alexander Edmonds you know whose work on
say plastic surgery or those of us who
are concerned about assisted
reproductive technologies you know that
some of these are in the sort of realm
of not life-saving but their quality of
life kinds of technologies and
interventions do people go to court for
those kinds of things in Brazil because
Brazil has a booming a-artie industry
for example so you know does this extend
beyond the the level of pharmaceuticals
those were things that I was wondering
hello I'd like to pick up on that point
but also introduce go back to the issue
that you said about how the
judicialization of for example
medications is very different from that
of sanitation so so I think it's
probably fair to say that the Brazilian
judicial system is is fairly inefficient
and but would like to get your opinions
on how that inefficiency you know I
would say it enforces a selective
pressure and what kind of and this is
related to the last set of questions and
how that inefficiency brings through
certain types of issues versus versus
others and is especially in the context
of sanitation or the other social rights
which are very you know one could make
the point much more important than
perhaps the the right to medications and
so forth those are great questions
it's to your question Marsha yes people
go to court to to demand access to to
plastic surgery for example some of the
they say so then the the question is it
static or it is therapeutic alright so
and then the argument is made in terms
of mental distress so it's so it gets
it's interesting so it gets medicalised
in that in that way and i and i think
some of those stories they also pop up
so one of the besides then the the the
extreme case of the which is very costly
to the budgets you know the new
therapies like enzyme replacement
therapies there are also the scandalous
cases you know then we have people
requesting surgery a trip to Miami or
together to get a surgery in New York
City and they tend to be the stories
that are picked up by the media and
based on those stories the scandalous
story you know that the main narrative
which which which somehow really creates
this
difficult public space for discussion
where people already are so polarized
bro or against mostly against set and
then it's enabled to really understand
this phenomenon and it's on its own its
complexity and and and and you know and
diversity the the question that you you
ask about the lawyers and and the
advocacy of the groups it's very
interesting there is already like an
industry also of litigant lawyers right
so so like who-who professionalize in
helping for people you know access the
courts in our sample it was not the
dominant but I would say is some twenty
twenty five percent of the cases I look
we're private lawyer so there's really a
niche for private lawyers to go there
I think overall what we see is this
phenomenon also democratization of
society so there was this you know this
massive investment on a discursive 'ti
of rights you know certain jurisprudence
as were created and I think people
started to pick up but unfortunately
they are not just fighting for the
collective right or for the systemic
change you know people have lives they
have complicated lives they have
interests and I think that is very hard
for us to reckon with these are
ambiguous subjects they are they want
something from the market they want
something from the state many times the
recognition they want from the state is
a commodity as well so in some ways over
the years by looking from the
perspective of the various actors in
this field I started to think of
judicialization as a para infrastructure
that to a certain extent helps all
parties involved the state preferred to
visualization why would they not given
one case try to reform a policy that
would affect all patients with diabetes
or all patients with who need a certain
formula like the girls here they could
have done that so they prefer to contest
which is the question you asked about
inefficiency right the state keeps the
likes the interest do digitalisation
because they can contest and then they
provide then they stop providing and
there's a new lawsuit that happens right
the the patients in my view they tend to
be reluctant this almost like a last
resort by and large they try to get it
through administrative channels locally
social workers say go judicial eyes
doctors say judicial eyes you need it I
want to treat you right and of course in
the in the in the spectrum of the of the
rare diseases genetic therapies the
doctors also want to experiment on the
patient's the doctors feel for decades I
couldn't do anything now there's this
possibility I want to see and there is
this tricky thing that without
experimentation what do we learn about
new generations of therapies so there is
a large scale experimentation going on
right and acknowledge Adriana
Petrino happens to be my wife my partner
she argues that that's missing in those
trials that our users mark is a is an
informed contract not just an informed
consent because patients and families
are giving value to these products right
so evidence would be one way to think
within the Marne a liberal frame but
there would be a way to think you know
what's owed to these patients to these
families etc etc but I really think the
the the the the immediate patient or the
patient sociation uses judicialization
to get access immediate so that is it's
like a meeting point of various actors
in lieu of a more an attempt of any kind
of infrastructure reform you know the
country is really falling apart
infrastructurally if you think so in
some ways a more positive view of this
individuals is that they carry
structural violence 'as structural
precariousness in their conditions and
in their plight you know maybe our duty
Butler you know they are saying you know
infrastructure is about a Commons you
know it's it's about it's about about
conditions of livability you know and
and to a certain extent people do that
and they instantiate new social
relations temporary collectives you know
and and again the question what does
that amount to it's a crucial one and I
and I totally agree with your question
about the judicial system as being
inefficient and I think there is this
dimension of of the of the judiciary
also wanting to affirm itself and gain a
certain political voice you know in the
broader field of governance so it helps
as well on that and that level I it's
very interesting I was telling Amy today
that for some reason last year we
created in Brazil and we created in
Princeton the Brazil lab those are for
Brazilian studies and one of our
colleagues in Brazil is supporter of
this initiative salchow if you really
want to do something meaningful you have
to talk to these environmentalists in
the Amazon a really mapping
deforestation working towards
conservation working with vulnerable
communities riverbank communities
without those communities there can be
no conservation etcetera etcetera so we
brought them to Princeton and to talk to
us and it's very interesting how they
use also the public ministry and the
judiciary to fight for conservation and
protection of vulnerable communities
it's not a formula maybe now it will
change now maybe in the end the
judiciary will rule against them because
inefficient but in the meantime they
produced evidence on the forest station
they went to the public ministry who
and could then threatened farmer large
ranchers take them to court and they
decided not to do so there's something
like if there's an interstitial space
that is created through this in
judicialization or through
judicialization yet at least buys time
right but absolutely I don't think this
is not equal to a systemic change and
and I don't know if where we are now in
Brazil no in United States of America if
that's even a possibility if not we are
not cheating ourselves being evermore
myopic right if we do not need to think
of other ways to intervene politically
you know maybe the scale is lower
because there's such a massive
dismantling taking place and which tools
do we have you know to fight if not that
is mantling other forms of mobilization
that might as berg Allah will say you
know to create some conditions of future
II I that's a great place to end so
please join me in thanking professor
Beale thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]